so
the next piece of the seven hours of
missing call logs story
is the obviously unbelievable claim from
donald trump that he doesn't even know
what burner phones are
so as a reminder yesterday we reported
to you
white house records turned over to the
january 6th committee are missing about
seven and a half hours of logs this is a
key seven and a half hours while the
insurrection was going on and one of the
sort of notable things
that came out of this was that donald
trump denied
having any idea what a burner phone is
in a statement monday night trump said i
have no idea what a burner phone is to
the best of my knowledge i have never
even heard the term
this stunk to high heaven and when i
told you this yesterday the story we
didn't know about john bolton's recent
comments
it was not plausible that trump didn't
know the term burner phone
and it was certainly not plausible that
trump doesn't know
about disposable phones
if you wanted to be as charitable as
possible and give trump the benefit of
the doubt which i don't know why we
would do at this point but let's say we
did you might be able to argue trump
knows of them as disposable phones
and he doesn't know or remember the term
burner phone but that it wasn't even
believable it really wasn't
we now have new reporting from donald
trump's former national security adviser
who says he specifically remembers trump
using the term burner phones and of
course this is completely believable and
completely obvious and it's what we
suspected right away
cbs news reporting john bolton the
former national security adviser to
trump told cbs news he heard trump use
the phrase burner phones in several
discussions and that trump did know
exactly what it meant
in a response trump said he never heard
the phrase burner phone i have no idea
what a burner phone is to the best of my
knowledge i've never even heard the term
bolton says he and trump spoke about how
people have used burner phones to avoid
having their calls scrutinized
um i mean
you know
i know trump's not the brightest
but it did not pass the sniff test that
trump didn't know what a burner phone
was
and this is increasingly reeking of
watergate i would encourage everybody in
the audience who is disturbed by this
story as you should be and you want to
read a little bit more about it there's
a really good new piece in the new
republic by alex shepard called trump's
missing phone records have a familiar
stink of criminality
and in that article
alex shepherd
discusses the analogies here to
watergate and
mentions that in terms of the amount of
missing phone data
it is more than 20 times longer in terms
of a gap in the records than what there
was in the watergate tapes i don't know
how many have recently reviewed
watergate and all of its different
elements but one of the things about
watergate was a gap in tapes which
ultimately scandalized richard nixon and
led to his resignation in 1974
and the gap in the record with these
trump phone calls is more than 20 times
bigger than the gap in that
in the watergate tapes the difference of
course is that at the time richard nixon
was president and so the entire scandal
precipitated his resignation trump is no
longer president and of course you and i
would like to think if people are
reasonable republicans would say okay
even if i liked his tax plan this is
just too much i can't vote for the guy
in 2024. unfortunately
that's not the case and not only are
there tens of millions of voters at
least still willing to vote for donald
trump still eager to vote for donald
trump in 2024
they become more emboldened by these
stories if you go and you look at
right-wing youtube right-wing twitter
right-wing tick-tock shows like real
america's voice and news max and all
these different places you see that they
are actually emboldened by these stories
saying these are part of the witch hunt
attacks meant to take down trump
unfairly
we renew our support for him
as a result of this investigation which
is really scary stuff we'll have all
these articles and more on our instagram
you can follow us there at david pakman
show we'll take a break we will talk
about that rick scott 11 point wacky
plan
after this short break